ولرسده تطورات الميدانيه من كيف ينضم
الينا مراسل الجزيره حسن الشوبكي ومن
موسكو مدير مكتب الجزيره زاور شاوج وابدا
مع زاور واخر التصريحات الخاصه من مالك
شركه فاغنر وتقدم قواته الى قرب وسط
المدينه كيلو متر من مركز المدينه كما قال
بالضبط زين العابدين
مالك شركه فاقينر متواجد منذ ان دخلت
المعركه على مدينه في
المراحل الحاسمه انصحها التعبير موجود في
ارض المعركه اليوم قام بجوله حاول ان
يرصدها بمقاطع فيديو من داخل مدينه باقبوت
تم تاكيد عبور قوات فاجنر لما يعرف بنهر
بخ موتك وهو نهر يقسم المدينه فعليا الى
قسمين انتقلت القوات المواليه لروسيا قوات
فاقدر الى الضفه الغربيه ودخلت مصنع عزومه
ومصنع
لتحويل
الحديد الصلب الى صفائح وهذا من اهم
المصانع في تلك المنطقه ويتمتع بشبكه من
الانفاق وكان
هذا المراكز المتحر المحصنه من الجانب
الاوكراني الذي مازال
الشخصيتين قائد الاركان ووزير الدفاع
واشار ايضا الى مركز تواجد القوات قوات
فاجنر في في مدينه
باغموت كما ذكرتها زين اللاعبين انها تقف
على بعد تقريبا كيلو متر و200 متر من
العاصمه او المركز الاداري لهذه المدينه
في وسط باخت ليتابع ما قاله بريجوجن في
هذا الشان من وسط ضخمه
[تصفيق]
عند ذلك المبنى المؤلف من خمسه طوابق حيث
يتصاعد الدخان يوجد مبنى اداره المدينه
وسط باخموت يبعد مسافه 1200 متر تقريبا من
هنا وفي هذا الاتجاه سيحاول الاوكرانيون
القيام بهجوم معاكس من الشمال بالنسبه لنا
من المهم ان يقدم لنا دعم ناري لحمايه
الاطراف وان لم يحدث فسنصبح محاصرين وسط
بخموت
طبعا ايضا
حسن الشوبكي تصريحات ايضا من قائد الجبهه
الشرقيه ومن قياده هيئه الاركان فيما
يتعلق بجبه باخمه تتحدث عن ان ما يقال عن
سقوطها في ايدي
فاجنر ليس صحيحا وان القوات الاوكرانيه ما
زالت تقاتل وربما تستمر حتى بدء هجوم
الربيع
زين العابدين بالفعل يعني قائد الجبهه
الشرقيه او وهو ايضا قائد القوات البريه
اكد اكثر من مره وكان له تاكيدات صباح
اليوم بان القتال يشتد في منطقه باخمت وان
كل يوم تكسبه القوات الاوكرانيه من القتال
في باقي هو لصالحها باعتبار ان هذا الامر
يزيد في استنزاف القوات الروسيه من حيث
المبدا وكذلك
بالاضافه الى يعني التجهيزات الكبرى التي
تقوم بها القوات الاوكرانيه في هذه
المنطقه
للبدء بهجوم معاكس او هجوم مضاد في معركه
ما تسمى معركه الربيع اليوم وايضا حتى من
الطرف الروسي جاءت انباء عن وجود تحركات
من محور الزبرجيا للقوات الاوكرانيه
باتجاه ضخمه من زبروجيا الى باقمه المسافه
تبعد نحو 250 كيلومتر لكن الاشتداد
المعارك كان اكبر منذ ظهيره اليوم وكما
يعني اورد زميل حسان مسعود من تلك المنطقه
وما جرى وحدث مع فريقه
يعني تم تصويره
وعرضه على شاشه الجزيره القول بان بالفعل
ان هنالك قصف شديد للمنطقه الغربيه لطريق
من
كستانتنا وايضا باتجاه كرامه الطريق ما
بينهما الى ضخمه هنالك طريق ترابي تستخدمه
القوات الاوكرانيه في هذا المجال وان
القصف على المنطقه الغربيه هو الاكبر كان
معهد دراسه الحرب قد تحدث عن ان الاشكاليه
في طريقه عمل القوات الروسيه
هي في انها مسره على الذهاب الى المنطقه
الصناعيه ولا تقوم بعمليه التطبيق الغربي
يبدو انهم قد بداوا بالفعل بعمل ذلك على
صعيد القاده العسكريين هنا في
كييف لا توجد تصريحات في خصوص المعارك
معارك اليوم في باق مت لكن الرئيس
بلديومير
تحدث عبر صفحته في تيليجرام بالقول ان
ارضنا محتله وهذا القول على
قواتنا تقاتل هناك ولا سبيل لنا الا ان
نصد اي عدوان باتجاه ارضنا هذا ما تحدث به
بالاضافه الى ذلك كان هناك تصريحات من
قياده الاركان زين العابدين تشير بشكل
واضح الى ان هنالك خسائر في صفوف ميليشيا
باجنر القول كان ان هنالك اكثر من الف
قتيل في اوساط
وحصيله الخسائر في القوات الروسيه منذ بدل
الحرب وحتى اليوم قالت قياده الاركان انها
بلغت نحو 158 الفا ما بين قتيلا وجريح في
هذه المعارك التي تشتد معركه باخمه مضى
عليها اكثر من سبعه اشهر والقوات
الاوكرانيه تؤكد مرارا على لسان قادتها
العسكريين بانها تستنزف القوه الروسيه في
هذا المحور وانها تستعد لهجوم مضاد في
الربيع على صعيد التسليح زين العابدين
يمكن القول بان وزير الدفاع النرويجي قدم
منظومات الدفاع الجوي الميداني المتعلقه
بنسمز
منشاتين في او منظومتين في هذا المجال لكن
القوات الاوكرانيه طبعا شكلت له ذلك لكن
القوات الاوكرانيه تطالب بمنظومه الدفاع
الجوي الميداني الامريكيه
ويطالب قائد الجيش الاوكراني زلوجني بسماء
مغلقه
وطائرات اف 16 الامريكيه كي تصد كل
الهجمات الروسيه حسنا شوكي منك شكرا جزيلا
لك وشكرا للزاور الشاوش من موسكو